we had a little wine I'm not gonna try
to you guys Kylie and Kendall Jenner
went live on Instagram Wednesday and
maybe should have rethought that wine oh
she just fell she just fell okay bye
she's wasted yeah like they were a
little tipsy
like literally Kendall tipped over
Kendall by Kylie cosmetics coming very
soon
here's what went down
the sisters stopped by the Kylie
cosmetics office with their pal Harry
Hudson to shoot a YouTube video for the
upcoming Kendall collab Kendall is
joining the Kylie cosmetics team and so
excited we have our collection coming
we're wearing it right now actually we
are super stoked about it
can you guess what colors are in her
palette the sisters have hinted at a
collab for a while now I feel like we're
really going big cuz I'm the I'm her
full blood like when Kendall stopped by
Ellen and said there was just one holdup
I had a contract before with another
makeup company so now I'm able to do it
anyway the collab is officially on the
way and the Jenner sisters even revealed
what the lip kit packaging looks like
someone screenshot this look at my face
don't have to tell us twice and
screenshot I can't decide what the
highlight of this instil I've is Kendall
and Kylie teasing their collab that
freaky screenshot or Kendall falling
over in her chair
oh she just felt oh she just felt okay
bye
she's wasted Who am I kidding it's
definitely Kendall falling over in her
chair she's wasted hashtag wine drunk
and relatable
the sisters insta live follows their
recent family getaway Kendall Kylie
their big sister Kourtney Kardashian
Scott Disick Kim Kardashian and all
their kiddos jetted off to Wyoming it's
also there
Kylie's man and dad to her two-year-old
daughter stormy Travis Scott the 28 year
old rapper hit up Instagram on
Wednesdays to share some snaps from the
vacay including this one
where he and his little girl are rocking
matching Bray's cute as for Kylie she
shared this sweet mommy daughter pic
writing woke up in the wild wild west
Kylie and Travis have been spending a
lot of time together during quarantine
amid the corona virus pandemic I'm
excited about it over the weekend they
were spotted out with friends at
celebrity hotspot the nice guy in
Hollywood back in March ET learned that
Kylie and Travis were officially back
together following their October 2019
let us all DT quote the couple has
always had love and respect for one
another but took a break last year
because they both had so much going on
they couldn't fully focus on what it
took to make the relationship work
[Music]